في الروايه
يعني نقطه مهمه عن رفض كتابه برقيه الشكر
للرئيس لانه سيطلق سراحك او صراح صديقك
احد ابطال الروايه ايضا واعتقد انه هذا
حصل مع
ربما مع المئات والالف العديد من الفكره
الرفض هنا من اين نبعث تحديدا
يعني هي عمليه اذلال
انه تجد الجن 15 سنه وبعد 15 سنه تجبرني
انا اكتب لك برقيه
اشكرك فيها
اي حكت عليها من فتره قرات انا كنت مقالي
عن كتاب لباحث ايرانيه اسمها شريعه
الطلقاني ايه بتحكي فيها عن
خلينا نقول دوافع الموجوده لدى النظام
السوري هو عن ادب السجون السوري وعن
السجون السوريه الكتاب اللي كاتبته الباحث
الايراني
فهي بتعزي الامر
لدافعين اساسيين
الدافع الاول هو تحطيم الانسان من الداخل
بحيث يفقد قدرته في المستقبل على اي فعل
معارض لهذا النظام
والدافع الثاني لدى النظام
لهذه الجرعه من التعذيب هو ان يعيش
الانسان ذلا يدفعه الى ان يكون مواليلا
بمعنى صحيح انه يعني كان يحصل ذلك لدرجه
انه احيانا يجبر البعض على كتابه هذا
التعهد بالدم كتير ناس كتبوا يعني يجبرون
على ذلك
وفي بعض الناس يعني
وهاي هلا في بعضهم اجبر لكن في كثير
يعني خلينا نقول نمط من التفكير
البراغماتي انه انا بدي ساوي ما بتاثر علي
ويعني هاي المنطقه التبريري هذا يعني
بيكتبوا بس انه انا بدي اخلص باي طريقه
يعني
كما فهمنا من الروايه انه الاعتراف اللي
تستند الى الكثير من الحقائق انه الاعتراف
احيانا بيكون يضعف المعتقل اكثر
بمعنى انه بصير يطلب منه اكثر يعني مجرد
ان يطبخ هو هذا هذا في بدايه الاعتقال في
البدايه في البدايه عندما يكون التعذيب
بهدف انتزاع معلومات عن التنظيم اذا كان
الشخص هذا ينتمي الى تنظيم سياسيا معارض